combien de combien de centimètres la mer
va telle montée en france à cause du
réchauffement climatique
s'il est un endroit où cette question
importe le plus c'est sans doute en
bretagne sur l'île de sein
poser à fleur d'eau à peine protégée par
des digues très fatigué lille pourrait
elle un jour être submergé
[Musique]
sur l'île il y a les optimistes toute
façon déjà de voir cette petite langue
de terre comme ça sur l'eau si ces trucs
complètement déchiqueté blement ça tient
un peu du miracle donc les miracles
masse est fait pour eux
c'est un atout énorme
il y a ceux qui ne veulent surtout pas
en entendre parler je sais pas comment
vous dire ça ça me gêne et des histoires
comme ça me gêne pas non plus a mis à me
projeter dans à réfléchir à me dire
qu'un jour il peut disparaître et j'ai
pas envie de penser à ça et puis il y
aller réaliste comme le maire de lille
faut savoir qu'une grosse partie de
l'huile de sang et des gens dessous du
niveau de la mer donc avec une montée
des eaux de 20 cm pour nous ça devient
déjà inquiétant
[Musique]
les scientifiques ne sont guère
rassurants pour jean jouzel glaciologue
membre du giec et coup détenteur du prix
nobel
même si on peut encore se battre pour
ralentir le phénomène
la montée des eaux est inéluctable on ne
peut pas arrêter la mer de monte c'est
bien ça notre problème pour le 21e
siècle je dirais que la machine est
lancée et disons je crois que nous
serions heureux
d'une certaine façon de ne connaîtra une
élévation du niveau de la mer que de
quelques dizaines de centimètres à mais
déjà 40 cm ce sont 100 millions de
personnes qui doivent déménager de leur
voie une ville mais il ya cette crainte
effectivement que d'ici la fin du siècle
on puisse avoir des d une élévation
moyenne du niveau de la mer de l'ordre
dumetz est pas impossible
ce qui est sûr c'est que le scénario des
experts du climat du giec qui annonçait
en 2007 jusqu'à 59 centimètres de montée
du niveau de la mer est déjà dépassée
car ce rapport ne tenait pas compte de
l'évolution des glaciers en antarctique
et au groenland
or ce qu'il se passe là-bas sider les
chercheurs nous avons joué en
visioconférence à la veille d'un départ
d'expédition eric rignot responsable de
mission à la nasa
[Musique]
la réalité dépasse dépasse les
prédictions de très loin donc on est on
est on est on est tous un petit peu je
dirais en état de choc par parler
l'évolution très rapide du climat et des
éléments du climat en ce qu'on va en
antarctique montré une accélération des
pertes de masse encore plus rapide qu'au
groenland
visuellement ça se traduit par la glace
qui vise sur le socle rocheux beaucoup
plus rapidement tout toute la glace
devient comme si elle devenait un petit
peu plus fluide et descendez beaucoup
plus rapidement vers la mer on pense à
tort que c'est la fonte des glaces qui
augmente le niveau de la mer or c'est la
chute et non la fonte de ces masses
gigantesque comme des glaçons qui tombe
dans un verre d'eau qui provoque la
hausse du niveau de la mer
[Musique]
si on ajoute les contributions du
groenland antarctique et les glaciers
continentaux est la hausse du niveau des
mers due à l'expansion thermique on
arrive à une prédiction d'environ un
mètre cinquante pour l'horizon 2100 avec
une marge d'incertitude d'environ admis
m
ce pourrait donc être un maître
voire 2 mètres dans le pire des cas les
habitants de l'île de sein n'arrive pas
à concevoir un tel avenir mais vous
croyez qu'il y aura un mètre de plus mis
dans un siècle vous croyez mais même si
ici comment on fait attention si les
gens france prenne conscience que que
moi je ne crois pas trop qu'il y avait
un mètre de plus bonjour je vois pas ça
je vois pas mettre plus parce qu'il y
avait de plus c'est fini les habitants
de l'île de sein trouve déjà que les
oules sont beaucoup plus forte qu'avant
et ils ont le sentiment d'avoir basculé
dans une autre dimension depuis la
tempête de mars 2008
le gardien de phare serge quoi teneur se
souvient de chaque instant on assiste
est un événement il a avant le 10 mars
il ya eu après le 10 mars
c'était le soir ces sept heures du soir
19h donc il ya une lumière un peu de
gérer passion du monde mais c'était cet
étonnant qu'on aime les gens allaient du
nord au sud et de sud au nord en disant
alors j'espère sa part été plus long
parce que c'était l'eau est montée
jusqu'à l'église est redescendu sous
casque fin c'était
10 l espoir possible pour y est pas un
je ne sais pas un spectacle d'hier
s'était passé le plus spectacle il y
avait beaucoup de silence
on ne parlait pas beaucoup c'est
justement dire on se regardait ont lancé
des regards du salut mon côté
[Musique]
aucun climatologue nous affirmer
aujourd'hui que les tempêtes deviendront
plus fréquentes ou plus violente mais
puisque la mère se rapprochera des
habitations
ces tempêtes feront inévitablement plus
de dégâts
[Musique]
en méditerranée en rouge apparaissent
les zones qui seront sous l'eau en 2005
en jaune ce sont les zones entre 1 et 2
mètres d'altitude qui seront alors
frappé par des tempêtes décennale entre
2 et 3 mètres d'altitude les habitations
en front de mer
hors d'atteinte aujourd'hui ne seront
plus à l'abri des tempêtes
exceptionnelles
[Musique]
ces risques sont encore largement
ignorée dans le languedoc roussillon
ici c'est un peu comme si la montée de
la mer ne concernait que l'autre bout de
la planète les régions exotiques fort
lointaine pourtant ce royaume des pieds
dans l'eau compte 5000 logements situés
à moins d'un mètre d'altitude
je réalise pas que la mère puisse - clim
je vois pas je vois pas ce que ça
pourrait faire je vois pas pourquoi elle
mènerait comme ça je crois pas je
préfère ne pas y croire
voilà mais je ne sais pas n'hésitez pas
une poignée de chercheurs disséminés en
france se préoccupe des aujourd'hui de
la montée des eaux
nicole le nôtre du brgm le bureau de
recherches géologiques et minières
travail sur l'impact du changement
climatique sur tout le littoral français
son but est d'évaluer les risques et les
solutions possibles pour faire face à
une hausse du niveau de la mer d'un
mètre d'ici 2100 à ses proches ont donc
des quais une tempête ça tape ici et
donc avec un mètre de plus cela d'une
façon leur l'affranchissement la dune
voilà elle est la plus son rôle de
barrière naturelle et les soucis sauf
que jean le vieux
dans le cadre d'une élévation du niveau
de la mer on parle maintenant
classiquement de 2,1 m on
c'était d'une là ne pourront plus jouer
le rôle lors des tempêtes ça veut dire
que ça ira franchissement très très
fréquemment
donc il faut en prendre conscience dès
maintenant pour essayer de le gérer de
gérer et de vivre avec ça on va pas
pouvoir bétonné partout et construire
par mettre des digues partout donc qu'il
faut qu'on conserve ou c'est fragile et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
ici c'est menacer ses maisons en front
de mer sont menacés en 2100 c'est un
mètre en 2100 c'est pas de suite mais il
faut en intérêt à anticiper vue de la
plage tout cela semble bien loin ben à
2100 serait mort le soir et les
fédérations du hainaut après un siècle
de style alfa moi c'est surtout embêtant
pour tous les gens qui habitent à bornéo
et donc moi dans 50 ans je serai plus là
hein tu entends alors donc ça m'inquiète
pas outre mesure
seul mandat m les vertus rien n'existe
un mètre de plus ça donnera quoi la
situation de palavas-les-flots inquiète
les chercheurs car la ville est cernée
par l'eau d'un côté les étangs de
l'autre la mer avec un mètre de plus
certains quartiers seront condamnés dans
les agences immobilières locales les
maisons les pieds dans l'eau restent les
plus demandés et les plus chers mais
qu'adviendra-t-il de la valeur de ses
propriétés dans quelques décennies
le secteur de l'immobilier apprécie peu
le travail des chercheurs comme nicole
le nôtre parfois accusées d'alarmisme
pointé du doigt les zones à risque et
délicat encore plus délicat essayer de
limiter leur développement
alors elle joue la prudence la tolérance
je pense qu'on peut pas être ayatollahs
parce qu'il ya des contraintes
il ya d urbanisation des usines des tas
de choses qui existent dans ces zones là
il faut qu'elle continue à vivre il faut
composer avec ce qu'on a fait dans le
passé
par contre on maintenant qu'on sait
c'est pas la peine de continuer à en
rajouter en normandie en 2100 des villes
balnéaires mais aussi des secteurs très
industrialisée pourront être inondée par
des tempêtes centennale c'est à dire des
tempêtes qui ont un pour cent de chances
de se produire chaque année des zones
seveso seront concernés même souci pour
le nord-pas-de-calais qui sera également
durement touchée car la mer pourrait
s'avancer assez loin dans les terres
bon
à cayeux-sur-mer la menace de la montée
des eaux est connu il paraît que chacun
sa croix il paraît qu'un jour ce sera
recouvert caillou un mètre d'ici 2100
pour nous ça fera quoi c'est énorme
énorme pour nous toute la partie au bout
de clayeux à mon avis ce sera sous l'eau
après tron sera amené à abandonner la
ville le problème c'est que cayeux sur
mer et tous les champs et villages qui
l'entourent sont situés en dessous du
niveau de la mer lors de la tempête de
1990 la digue qui protégeait la région a
cédé depuis empêcher la mer d'avancé est
devenu un combat titanesque
l'ancien président du syndicat mixte
pour l'aménagement de la côte picarde
jean christian cornette se souvient
parfaitement de cette tempête dramatique
et 90 et c'est une ville qui a failli
être avalés par la mer c'est cinq nuits
tempête 5 marais consécutive avec et
surcote de plus d'un mètre des galets
qui veulent par tous un mètre d'eau dans
les rues et les 3000 hectares inondés
christophe engrenage dont la ferme est
située à plus d'un kilomètre de la mer
se retrouvent aux premières loges durant
une heure de temps on a eu un mètre
cinquante d'eau dans la cour et beaucoup
d'exploitations beaucoup de maisons
aussi plusieurs hameaux noyés parce
qu'on est en contrebas de la mer on est
un mètre cinquante sous niveau des mers
ici on est parti de la ferme pendant
quinze jours
tellement qu'il fait des vagues courant
terrible c'était comme en pleine mer ici
cette mère qui envahit tout fait la une
des journaux le gouvernement se mobilise
on savait pas qu'ils allaient venir donc
ça on savait pas surtout qu'ils allaient
visiter la ferme
mitterrand arrive en hélicoptère et dit
qu'il faut sauver ce pays et donc à
partir de là on décide de maintenir le
trait de côte là où il est et toute la
machine se met en marche une machine
colossal on va construire des épis sur 7
km de côtes tout au sud de cayeux pour
protéger l'intérieur des terres 19
millions d'euros plus tard on arrête cet
ouvrage gigantesque aux portes de la
ville par manque d'argent et parce que
les habitants ne veulent pas que leurs
plages soit défigurée le problème c'est
que ces constructions vont déplacer
l'érosion vers le nord très vite après
le dernier répit la mer attaque la plage
kai hotu n'était pas directement menacée
le devient donc à sa pointe sud
[Musique]
alors pour protéger la ville les hommes
vont désormais amoncelés des montagnes
de galets
cette benne pare au plus pressé car ce
sont en fait dix mille camions qui
chaque année des verts sur la plage 170
mille tonnes de galets pour empêcher la
mer d'avancé
les galets apportées sont très vite
emporté par les vagues
il faut donc que les camions rapporte
toujours et encore des galets un cercle
vicieux qui a valu à cayeux le surnom de
sisyphe sur mer la ville où l'on joue au
chat d'oc sur la plage un point de vue
peu apprécié par monsieur le maire il
m'a c'est alors n'est pas du tout
l'expression de shadocks parce que les
shadoks faisait des choses inutiles et
répétitive
pour nous ce ce transport par camion
entre le nord et le sud est est absolue
est très utile puisqu'il assure la
sécurité de cayeux actuelle utile ou
absurdes
en tout cas plutôt irrationnelles comme
le souligne la géographe vincent atteint
le coût de la défense des bas-champs
decayeux donc les travaux de la digue
avec les épier les rechargements de
galles et avoisine aujourd'hui les 50
millions d'euros pour une portion de
trait de côte de 7 km de long c'est une
somme d'argent énorme je me comprends je
le comprends très très bien mais on est
obligé de se protéger si on laisse
rentrer la mère c'est pas quelques
fermes qui vont c'est toute une ville
entière qui est menacée
cette volonté de se défendre à tout prix
contre la mère a été la stratégie du 20e
siècle
que ce soit à cayeux-sur-mer ou ici dans
le languedoc-roussillon
ce choix et puis surtout les finances
et les hommes car ces brises lames ses
épis engendre toujours les mêmes effets
pervers on se protège des tempêtes mais
c'est le voisin qui trinquent
[Musique]
le littoral du languedoc roussillon
n'est plus qu'un immense champ dépit qui
renvoie toujours l'érosion ailleurs
comme ici à vias où l'on tente
désespérément de se protéger avec ses
murs est dérisoire qui en fait ne font
qu'accentuer le problème
[Musique]
oui
il est vrai que tous ces ouvrages en dur
rassure spécialiste du littoral à
l'université de perpignan
raphaël certains expliquent volontiers
aux habitants les problèmes liés à tous
et enrochements il remet notamment en
question ces digues parallèle au
littoral qui semblerait pourtant une
bonne solution pour parer à la montée
des eaux
ils sont très efficaces pour protéger le
parking lui même de la subversion
par contre ils sont pas détruits
efficaces pour maintenir la plage en
l'état donc si ce qu'on veut c'est
continuer à mettre des gens sur une
plage qui vient de bronze et l'été c'est
totalement inadapté si ce qu'on veut
c'est protéger le parking à tout prix
quitte à voir la pl disparaître ils sont
adaptés en fait à chaque fois que la
mère tape contre ces ouvrages en dur l
emportement cette plage
pour l'avenir on pense désormais qu'il
faut changer de logique limiter les
ouvrages en dur et utiliser d'autres
solutions pour protéger le littoral
on va ainsi chercher du sable en mer
pour recharger les plages et compenser
l'érosion
censé rechargement en sable cette plage
des pyrénées-orientales soumise à une
très forte érosion n'existerait plus il
fait beau aujourd'hui un pierrois maire
de sainte marie a voulu tester d'autres
technique pionnière dites douces on
s'est renseigné on a vu qu'en hollande
pour se protéger de la mer qui est plus
haute que la terre il mettait des gros
boudin anjou textile remplis de sable
compose au fond de la mer quand une
entreprise de marseille qui entretient
les ports qui nous a fait ça bon le géo
tubau dû être vraiment gonflé il est un
peu galette 1
mais quand même ça nous a bien protégé
la place la plage série engraisser
puisque il y avait sept buts et
duplicable aucune somme ces solutions
douces suffiront-elles face à la montée
des eaux
le rechargement c'est quelque chose qui
doit être refait périodiquement on
évoque des périodes de cinq à dix ans
suivant les sites n'a pas des sources
illimitée en sable pour les ramener sur
les plages
donc de fait on va se retrouver là aussi
dans 20 ou 30 ans dans un problème pour
le rechargement à la fin du siècle
avec les mêmes problèmes qui vont être
accentués je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive
avec tout ce panel de deux solutions à
maintenir l'ensemble des infrastructures
oh
on peut également douter de nos
capacités à gérer la montée des eaux
pour une autre raison de nombreuses
portions de notre littoral ne
résisterait pas aujourd'hui à une
tempête similaire à celle de 1999
notamment à cause de dick défectueuses
ou non entretenues
[Musique]
alors que faire
reculer ce que l'on n'arrivera pas à
protéger
c'est l'idée qui petit à petit s'imposer
en france
ainsi cette route reliant sète à
marseillan était régulièrement dévoré
par les tempêtes
soit on la reconstruisent est à chaque
fois soit on l'a reculait
[Musique]
on a donc choisi d'abandonner la route
près de la mer et d'éloigner la nouvelle
route en la collant le nom du tgv ce
gigantesque chantier est le premier et
unique exemple en france de recul
stratégique
ce ne devrait pas être le dernier
[Musique]
reculer devant la mer cette idée avait
été envisagé pour la ville de kayes eux
afin d'en finir avec les frais d'un
combat titanesque est sans fin mais
cette proposition de jean christian
cornette avait alors énormément choqué
quand j'ai abordé la question du recul
je me suis retrouvé en situation
d'accusés de manière extrêmement dure et
que j'ai assez mal vécu cette chose
c'est vrai que c'était très compliqué
des tracts les insultes d'être anonyme
on n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le droit
de regarder les choses au delà d'un
mandat électoral c'est comme ça dans ce
pays
cette question se reposera un jour j'en
suis persuadé et je me dis que très
sereinement
il faut oser regarder l'avenir et il
faut cesser de défier la nature
aujourd'hui encore l'idée passe mal on
est là depuis quatre générations déjà il
y avait déjà du monde avant nous c'est
c'est sûr de reculer reculer c'est
'circulez le problème aussi
les chercheurs savent bien que cette
idée de recul sera la moins populaire la
plus difficile à faire avaler
je dirais qu'il ya quelques années c'est
un déni en nier le problème les gens
maintenant sont plus réceptifs alors
après quand ça touche leur maison c'est
plus dans l'affectif c'est autre chose
mais on
il ya un changement et au niveau
ministériel et même au niveau maintenant
les maires ils en prennent conscience
oui n'est pas impossible que au fil des
ans si les tempêtes augmente si la mère
monde que il la première ligne de maison
n'a il ya les sept huit maisons en
première ligne seront obligés de tri
détruites et vous imaginez comment ça va
se passer a demandé aux gens de
déménager ça s'est déjà fait en montagne
lorsqu'il avait découlé de des coulées
de boue on a donc il ya une déclaration
d'utilité publique et l'expropriation
pour pour ces maisons là je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez vous mais bon moi me
dire de recul et ma maison alors que
j'ai vue sur la mer j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver derrière on va en parler au
prochain conseil syndical on va leur
demander de reculer l'immeuble une
dizaine de mètres ça
ce sera dur d'aller mètres plus loin
puisque je suis membre de l'eau comme ça
ça sera dur pour moi de partir avec
tivement et c'est pas n'importe quelle
maison quand même c'est la maison
familiale dans magicien j'ai une chine
attache familiale quand même le coeur
mon père qui l'a construite dans c'est
déjà énorme sur l'île de sein le
problème est encore différent
nous on fait comment un nom peut pas
reculer non obligés de rester là et on
va rester
si c'est ça c'est sûr nos enfants seront
je pense la même mentalité que nous ils
seront aussi têtu ça c'est s'ils sont là
ils voudront rester aussi nos anciens
bains eux n'ont jamais voulu partir
alors pourquoi voulez vous que nous donc
c'est sûr c'est se battre contre la
nature c'est une folie sans doute qu'on
ne gagnera pas cette bataille là mais
mais mais on va essayer de com de se
battre jusqu'au bout
à
rigole aujourd'hui le maire jean pierre
kerloc'h se bat pour faire restaurer les
digues et en construire de nouvelles
mais il se sent démuni face à la future
montée des eaux
dès que tu as une tempête terrible
tempête notamment une en pleine tempête
qui vient du nord c'est assez éloquent
on va voir on va voir comment notre île
fous l'camp
et là on voit bien la trace un la terre
la terre ce sédiment arrivait à peu près
jusqu'ici on voit bien les traces et
donc aujourd'hui sous le coup sous le
coup de la houle
on voit bien que tout s'écroule
on peut pas faire des digues partout on
peut pas faire des digues partout aller
chercher des cailloux sur le continent
on vous la cherchez des blocs sur le
continent ça reviendrait également rate
trop cher dans un endroit comme ça
malheureusement il n'y a pas beaucoup de
solutions
de plus en plus de français iront vivre
en bord de mer dans les 30 prochaines
années
la pression immobilière va donc
s'accroître dans des zones pourtant
concernés par la montée des eaux
il faudrait sévèrement contrôlé ce
développement
selon les chercheurs qui prône la
stratégie sans regret la stratégie sans
regret c'est est-ce que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui ne pas regretter de l'avoir
fait dans 50 ans on peut développer un
pas en arrière on n'est pas obligés de
développer les deux premières rondes
maison c'est surtout le monde va voir
vue sur mer quoique en aquitaine ils ont
la plupart les trois cinquièmes sont
dans la forêt n'ont pas vu sur mer et
c'est très bien accepté mais à
cayeux-sur-mer pas question de freiner
le développement des millions d'euros
viennent d'être débloqués pour sécuriser
la ville avec la construction de
nouveaux et pis les épices n'est pas
seulement pour protéger la population
caillou l'aise c'est évidemment la
priorité mais c'est également pour
permettre à cayeux de redémarrer
économiquement de pouvoir la voir une
vraie politique touristique dans le
futur
difficile pour un maire de freiner
aujourd'hui le développement de sa ville
sous prétexte que le niveau de la mer
sera plus élevée dans 50 ou 100 ans
je pense qu'il faut jamais baisser les
bras on ne sait pas quelles sont les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
et en attendant de les connaître
qu'est ce que va faire la population
locale elle a besoin de vivre ici pour
faire face à la montée des eaux
on se développait différemment en
faisant preuve d'imagination
c'est ce que suggère le géographe
passant matin soit on affronte la
dynamique littoral donc on va compte
construite compte soit on anticipe puis
on fait avec on peut apprivoiser la mer
faut réfléchir à des solutions
à plus long terme et qui pourrait être
plus écologique et moins coûteuse des
ingénieurs paysagistes ont ainsi imaginé
un avenir radicalement différent pour
cayeux et ses environs on laisserait la
mer envahir les bachand où l'on vivrait
sur des habitations sur pilotis cette
zone de marais maritime servirait de
zone tampon qui freinerait la sous des
vagues
les investissements de défense se
concentrerait uniquement sur cayeux qui
dans le cas des inondations
exceptionnelles se transformerait en île
[Musique]
messika lieu devient une île c'est une
très bonne idée
hollande ils ont une ville menacée par
la mer et ils ont lancé l'idée de faire
c'est de cette ville unique et ça a
généré un afflux d'investissements et
cette ville va devenir une île et est du
coup permis et les gens veulent habiter
sur des îles c'est fou parce il y a ceux
qui rêvent de se transformer en il est
des îles qui aimerait bien avoir les
pieds un peu plus sur terre qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
je voudrais bien qu'on trouve une
solution bon la surélever un peut-être
la protéger un petit peu plus même avec
des digues sera pas possible ce sera pas
possible c'est la mer monte à ce point
là on pourra pas tenir
[Musique]
quand je pense à tout ce qu'on a vécu
ici tout ce que l histoire de l'ailé me
dire qu'un jour elle n'existera plus
j'imagine même pas dans cette histoire
je pense à ma mère à mon père a à mes
enfants et je veux non moi je veux pas
quoi je vais pas
l'avenir s'annonce mal la mère ne
s'arrêtera pas de monter en 2100 si le
réchauffement persiste elle pourrait
dans quelques siècles montée de
plusieurs mètres et bouleverser
totalement notre littoral